the secretary general arrived in the
capital strong of an agreement in
principle to broke a humanitarian
corridor for the civilians holed up in
the azov style steel plant in mariupol
antonio guterres called it a crisis
within a crisis his meeting with
president volody mirzalenski that went
longer than schedule focused on this
issue but the secretary general didn't
want to give any specifics on any
progress
at the present moment i can only tell
you we are doing
everything we can
to make it happen
i'm not going to enter into any comment
that would undermine that possibility
because my first and only priority is
the people that suffer and the people
that must be rescued
the russians decided to use
ahead of his meeting the secretary
general had visited the devastated towns
north of the capital borodyanca erpinan
bucha where the u.n said there was
growing evidence of alleged war crimes
the ukrainian president had criticized
guterres for heading to moscow before
coming to keefe he said that the u.n
secretary general should have first seen
the trail of destruction left behind by
the russians
but guterres got also to experience
first-hand russian firepower
several cruise missiles targeted kiev
just as the press conference with the
president had ended
this was the first time the capital was
hit in several weeks for the ukrainian
president it was proof that without
security guarantees nothing can be
negotiated with russia
today right after our talks in kiev
russian missiles flew to the city five
missiles
this says a lot about russia's true
attitude towards global institutions
about attempts of russian authorities to
humiliate un and everything that the
organization represents therefore it
requires corresponding powerful reaction
a close adviser to president zielenski
said in a tweet
missile strikes in the downtown of kiev
during the official visit of antonio
guterres the day before he was sitting
at a long table in the kremlin and today
explosions are above his head postcards
from moscow recall why russia still
takes a seat on the u.n security council
if anything the attack on kiev
underlines how difficult it will be for
the international community to mediate a
settlement between the two sides for the
secretary general the priority at the
moment is to provide humanitarian relief
to ukrainians trapped in battle zones
al jazeera
al jazeera's heart abdal hamid spoke to
khaterish during his visit she began by
asking him about negotiations to create
a humanitarian corridor out of mariopol
where thousands of civilians and
fighters are trapped in a steel plant
i
went to meet president putin
he has agreed with me
in principle that the u.n and the icrc
could be involved uh
in this operation there has been intense
uh preparatory discussions on to to try
to make it a reality
i spoke also with president zielinski
and
i hope that
it will be possible but
the best way to make it happen
is not to start talking too much about
it
you went this morning to borodianka to
bucha to european you've seen for
yourselves the devastation of this war
and today this evening after wrapping up
your press conference
you seen or you experienced for yourself
kiev
under air strike
do you think
this was a message
one of
president zielenski's advisor
said on twitter that that was a postcard
from russia
and it was not a coincidence that it was
happening at this time while you are in
kiev i don't think i am so important
to justify
the uh
use of this day for for that purpose but
there haven't been any attacks
having said so
i must say that i was obviously shocked
when i
was informed
that
two missiles have
reached a target in kiev
i was shocked with that and
i think it's
very important
to spare this wonderful city kiev
is a city with an enormous historical
value keep is a is is
it represents
i would say everything for both
ukrainians and russians and i hope that
kiev will be spared when it comes to the
political track what can the u.n do and
are we anywhere close for the two sides
to sit together to try to bring any sort
of ceasefire the iran was always kept
out of the political negotiations and to
be fair to to be frank to you
i regret that that has happened that the
u.n was never invited to be part
of the
minsk process or the misc agreement or
of the normandy format but in fact
we were never
invited to be part of it and on the
contrary our presence was considered not
useful
and
we are not part of the present political
negotiations but we are following them
with a lot of interest and hoping that
they will
solve the problem and that peace will
come back and it is not by chance
that i went to moscow
stopping in ankara and speaking to
president erdogan
because turkey has been as you know very
active very engaged
er
bringing the parties to turkey to
istanbul to antalya and strongly
supporting those political discussions